first on CBS this morning we're taking
the sky to show you a new safety feature
designed to save lives two plane crashes
last week raised new questions about the
safety of small planes around 250 people
die every year in small plane crashes
but new technology gives pilots and
passengers the option of hitting what is
basically a panic button to
automatically land an aircraft it's
currently being certified by regulators
Kris Van Cleave took a test flight good
morning we are flying over Kansas right
now and we're about to show you some
brand new technology that really could
save lives it is an emergency
Auto land feature the buttons right
there if something were to happen to our
pilot here and I pushed it it would get
us safely on the ground at the nearest
airport that's a student pilot calling
for help in Australia in August he made
his first ever landing after his flight
instructor passed out but often on a
small plane there is only one pilot
while crashes due to pilot
incapacitation are relatively rare
they've killed at least 269 people in
the US in the last 10 years when
something happens to the pilot going
forward people live and today there's a
good chance that's not going to happen
if you have an incapacitated pilot
Garmin has designed new emergency auto
land technology it hopes prevents
crashes like that a professional golfer
Payne Stewart his private jet lost cabin
pressure knocking out the pilots the new
Auto land system is designed to self
activate when there's been a prolonged
period of no pilot activity it could
also prevent more common accidents
crashes like the one that killed John F
Kennedy jr. where it's believed he got
disoriented in weather and lost control
or where the plane is dangerously low on
fuel that would be a situation that wait
also they push the button and get the
airplane Erik sergeant is Garmin's test
pilot he took us up in a piper m600 with
the new system how confident are you in
this system to safely land
really confident I would put my family
in here in a heartbeat and be confident
that if they push the button if I wasn't
around that it would get them down
safely all a pastor has to do is lift
this push the button permit emergency
auto land activated the plane then picks
the closest airport from a list of
thousands worldwide where it can safely
land factoring in weather terrain and
the amount of fuel onboard it radios the
tower declares an emergency and updates
passengers on the approaching landing
the pilot can override the technology at
any point the emergency auto land system
is controlling all flight functions with
the runway in sight and sergeants hands
off the controls or going in for what
turned out to be a smooth hands-free
landing pretty much as good as a human
pilot it's going to be available first
in certain new piper airplanes and will
expand to other new aircraft I hope is
that in the near future it'll be able to
be added to existing aircraft as well
for CBS this morning Kris Van Cleave
flying over Kansas Wow does that give
you a comfort feelings but I mean I'm
very impressed that they can do that yes
very impressed that they can do that but
what are the other conditions that go
along with that I don't know it's pretty
amazing I didn't airport everything then
turn around on the seat say it's gonna
be okay and tap your knee I mean weather
was good everything was perfect the
conditions were great so flying planes
coming after town driving cars we're on
the way